she said uh you're paige right
and everybody knows who's dallas now
right then unless they know me you know
and then all my friends and my family
can't call me paige out in public
because it confuses people you know so
she says your page ready to go
yeah she goes me too
so you know who he was yes i recognized
him but i had never met him before got
it but how did you recognize me um i had
dated ira
the country musician like four or five
years before and he'd always told me
about this
wild you know
rambunctious wrestling friend named
diamond dallas page and i was never a
wrestling fan but i was like oh paige
what a great name and it resonated with
me like i just remembered it and when
the arthur video went viral
he was all over cnn and everything so i
was like oh that's ira's friend and just
coincidentally saw him the tsa line so
you see him in the tsa line you you know
you obviously think she's attractive um
yeah clearly yeah what was your pickup
line do you remember the line that he
used to kind of get in there you know i
really did it in this scenario because
when she said her name my name's page
two i go your name's page two and it
kind of really was yeah you know a
conversation builder and we ended up i
walked into a gate and we exchanged
numbers and nothing really came of it
right away and then i was coming into
nashville for
another time was it nashville or yeah
yeah and i was doing another autograph
you know signings that we do
and i said hey you want to go to uh you
know dinner uh you know you just and she
thought i was just like being a friend
in town wanting to hook up to to go to
dinner and then it turned into something
more than that and
we ended up seeing each other about
three times or three times exactly
and
at that point i never thought i was
going to be with one woman again i was
coming off of divorce years before that
and i was like i'm never getting married
again
and what ended up happening was he broke
up with me
but wait let me explain why yeah first
of all she's 18 years younger than me
and my first time sir yeah well you know
but my first wife and i split up because
i i did because of my body i'm in great
shape but um i don't want to go skiing i
don't want to go horseback riding i
don't want to do anything that can hurt
me i've already done all the damage
i want to say you know
good
and
she was like um you know so much she ran
hundred mile races
you know she put uh climb mount
kilimanjaro climb mount food uh
i was a professional athlete adventure
athlete so i wrote for national
geographic in a bunch of different
publications and i was like a generalist
so i climbed mountains all over the
world around ultramarathons and um
cycled across southeast asia like all
these things
and
i didn't realize that that intimidated
him well it wasn't intimidating i'm
thinking
kimberly and i split up because we're
still we're best friends still to this
day they just heard her husband just
stayed in our house
so your ex-wife will you have kids with
i say no that's you don't no i have my
two kids that i have i adopted who were
one of my best friends kim couldn't have
kids okay so one of my best friends
linda who's what my head of finance
today with my ddp yoga company she her
girls their sperm donor left when kimmy
was an infant and britney was seven okay
and so
right away from uncle paige i became dad
and right and now they're 35 and 26 holy
[ __ ] but but back to the
you're saying that your ex-wife and her
current husband stayed with you guys
just the other day yeah that's where we
came down walk me through that how are
you awkward at all not at donna
[Music]